so so one of the cool things about being
an academic once you're tenured right is
that you can do whatever you want sort
of but you do have to get money to do it
so there's this little conundrum is like
well but you don't know anything about
that what is this wearables thing so you
have to sort of figure out ways to you
know make your way and make it happen so
what I want to talk about today is
um social rationality how do how do
humans as a species survive I mean
presumably rationality means you sort of
know what you want know how to go get it
right that's a sort of you know back of
the envelope thing
um and sort of obviously we have done
pretty well till now because we're here
right uh and yet we Face a lot of
challenges uh global warming this that I
mean you can like name all these things
uh it behooves us to understand how we
as a species can make better decisions
and that also means organizations and
individuals and and want to understand
you know like what's going on and
um that actually is sort of a question
about you know how did our minds evolve
and what are the problems that biology
faces there's a very sort of basic
things that cut across a lot of fields
um and so I'm going to be risque and
sort of like venture out a little bit
into those things uh but the tools that
I use for this are computational social
science basically means
there are now data resources for human
behavior that are extensive millions of
people different sorts of behavior you
see this online a lot most people do
Twitter and stuff like that but you can
have access to lots of other things too
if you you know sign away your firstborn
that you will never leak data and you
respect privacy and things and privacy
is incidentally one of the places where
I've been probably most influential
because I help form uh the discussion
that led to gdpr right so that's
good not enough but good start
um so so we're we're going to be
respecting privacy we can ask about it
if you're interested but what I'm going
to talk about is what all this data says
about humans
and I think that when we think about
humans in design computer systems uh we
make a lot of fundamental errors
and I want to talk about those this is
like you know the emperor has no clothes
sort of thing
so let's start there
um
so first of all why are we a social
species you hear this right
and incidentally you know almost all the
models that you see in computer science
and other things are rational
individuals
those aren't social those are like
individuals you know guy who lives up in
the main forest and is you know it is
Shaq and thinks things you know or throw
except Thoreau did you know that
um so tarot Walden Pond all that he had
his mother do his laundry every week
it's like okay well that's enter it
wasn't really like isolated but so
um it would be good to know why we're
the way we are
in terms of survival and fitness if
we're going to Design Systems to make us
more fit and help us survive right
um and of course there's lots of reasons
that you hear about like greater rate of
cultural Evolution we can trade ideas
and invent things have them spread
um but I think that one of the things
that people Miss is there are some
fundamental mathematical structures
about this that we don't often think
about and I'm going to talk about those
a little bit okay so for instance
um long tail distributions
so we all know what a gaussian is right
and you know what like log normal has
had that sort of longer there are things
that are more long-tailed than that
um and then and just sort of an
illustration of that is like this right
there's the calcium and then there's a
fat tail you know no big deal we'll just
fit it with a gaussian right
except that with a fat tail you get
things that are well they're not quite
black swans
they're gray swans okay so these really
unusual things pop up
uh and and they're not in our models
because we're fitting things with
gaussians or stuff like that like for
instance after the 2008 financial crash
one of the senior people like the head
of Lehman who said this was a 26
standard deviation out event right
that's like BS okay 26 standard
deviations is like millions or billions
of times the lifetime of the universe
right no he had the wrong model and if
you look at Black Shoals the thing that
they were building derivatives with it
uses concentrated distributions it does
not admit for long tail events and they
got hit by a long tail event which was
part of the distribution because
um
if with these things if you sample from
this
typically what you'll get is something
that looks like a normal distribution
you can fit it with an older computer
well that might be one outlier
but if you do it again
you'll get a different mean and a
different variance
if you do it again you get a different
mean in a different because actually the
distribution is very wide
okay so you fit it this is a major
source of
failure of generalization in Ai and
machine learning is you fit it you get
something well that was great on my
sample the next sample you apply it to
has different statistics because it's
long pale the sad thing is that almost
all preferential attachment processes
and all Cascade processes
read almost everything social and
everything biology
are one of these two
right you all you understand what that
means
everything you look at is not gaussian
not everything lots of things okay
and what that means is that this nice
little notion that I can sample the
distribution and do you know a t-test on
or something
is wrong
so this is a nice little diagram A
friend gave to me so so if you're going
to use the statistics that all of you
use
right like most machine learning stuff
right and you've got a thought tail
distribution
you're going to be in bad shape
you are not going to get good
generalization
okay now uh if it's mixed you do quite a
bit better
but if you had the right statistics you
could do lots lots better
okay so that's interesting and you see
this in some science like in medicine
they do these very expensive randomized
control trials right
and then they don't pay attention to
them they do another one and another one
and another one why do they do that
so they can do a meta study right and
it's only when you see the meta study
that they begin to really believe it
what's that about I thought randomized
control trials were a gold standard
well except for confounders and except
for long tail distributions Oh you mean
like all those biological processes
yeah okay so meta Studies have
polynomial more samples and when you get
large enough samples then you really get
a characterization of the distribution
and the stuff you do can be meaningful
and generalize
okay so that's like okay
maybe that's part of why we're social
is that I can't do enough experiments
right like I can eat blue you know
blueberries and red berries and I find
the red berries make me sick but that's
not all red berries if I can observe a
lot of other people I can figure out
that hey red berries tend to make a lot
of people sick don't eat them right
blueberries are safe Everybody Eats them
I don't see anybody throwing up later
okay good social social is very powerful
for this sort of stuff but of course
that's not how we model humans in most
of these systems we model them you know
sort of Bayesian decision makers Maybe
uh Limited in various ways right and
that's sort of the fundamental thing
that you get in economics and all these
sorts of stuff and a lot of our
political systems are this way
you know we assume that people are
rational individuals
um but
that's a problem for a number of reasons
right so one thing is I just talked
about
the real world has Cascades
rumors panics Financial crashes
biological pandemics all of those things
don't admit very well of this type of
model you need to concentrate
information from lots of people to get
the evidence that you need
okay so that means you better pay
attention to other people and your math
your reasoning it better be long-tailed
rather than short tail okay that all
sounds very academic I know right but it
matters okay
um
the other thing is is you know most of
the way we reason oh my reason is the
past right this worked in the past so
it's work in the future
how many of you have ever invested money
in anything
and what is the little thing say at the
bottom past performance is not
indicative of future results or
something like that right yeah it's not
the world changes
um so what you need is something that's
very efficient use of data to be able to
keep up with the changes there's no way
to anticipate the future really well
unless you know the generative processes
but what you can do is you can have
something that updates the distributions
and the decisions you make constantly so
that you can deal with things pretty
well and you see this in Signal
processing all the time people know what
Nyquist uh limits are so this is like
you know the people who are doing the
electronics ran into the fact that
things changed too fast and they screwed
up really badly and they characterized
you know how how fast you have to update
in order to deal with changing signals
look it up if you're not familiar with
it
um
and of course in this rational decision
model there's this notion of how do you
integrate collective experience into the
decision now there's a lot of models
about this but people don't really
understand
Collective uh representation and
collective decision making
and I'm about to tell you
a lot of what I think is going on okay
and uh and this is where I'm sort of
getting out of my swim chart so what I
want to do is expand this rational
decision model to include continual
acquisition of both individual and
Collective knowledge
so I was like no no we're not going to
like say here's what we know and we
reason and blah blah no we're going to
be continually trying to figure out
what's going on
and the way we do that is this
recognize this formula all that
wonderful but in Behavior
this is uh known as foraging so most
animals have foraging Behavior what that
means is the rabbit comes out of his
hole goes eat some berries but sometimes
what it does is it goes tries to find
other berry bushes even though that
doesn't feed it
right so there's exploration to find
other food sources and exploitation to
keep yourself fed that's called the
exploitation exploration dilemma and
it's part of uh trying to figure out
what's going on in an uncertain
environment
and so really what this move is about is
saying look we live in an incredibly
uncertain environment I use this
computer all the time I'm pretty smart
about it but I don't know lots of what's
going on in there what I have is a bunch
of strategies for dealing with it
right that you know we're sort of an
explanation but if you push me I don't
really know and and when you get new
releases of software I figure out new
strategies and I pull my hair out and
stuff like that okay so it's it's not
like we have a knowledge base a
reasoning what to do all the time mostly
we're just trying to figure out how to
get along that's the attitude and you
see this in animals you see it in it's
called Thompson sampling or distributed
Thompson sampling uh or distributed
Bandit problems people know about Bandit
problems
okay abandoned problems are fun so uh
imagine you go into a casino
and there's all these one-armed Bandits
those are slot machines that's where the
name comes from okay and you know they
pay off different amounts so this one
will pay off lots of money right this
one won't but you don't know that
they're just a bunch of machines so you
have to try them to find out which ones
pay off best
and that's called Thompson sampling it's
a Bayesian process of exploration
and exploitation you want to make as
much money you can you don't want to
pull the wrong arms but you have to
explore because you don't know anything
about it and distributed
Bandit problems are you're watching the
other people
you say hey
that lady she's making a lot of money
over there and when she walks away I'm
gonna go over there and try that one
that's why I'm integrating Knowledge
from a bunch of people
and what I'm suggesting here is that as
opposed to
behavioral conditioning like you know
animals or cognitive reasoning like
individual reasoners that's more like us
we're just watching what's going on and
trying to figure out strategies that get
us what we want
that's just a more modest view of human
intelligence let's just say but it's
integrally social
because you're watching other people for
evidence
so what you're doing here is there's
individual rationality probably limited
I'll show you a little bit about that
but there's also a prior and in humans
and in many animals this prior comes
from observing other people
and like they ate the blueberries and
they didn't get sick blueberries are
good okay
right that sort of a thing and you can
see that that's something that we do
this gen these priors
are essentially Norms of behavior
they're the elements of our culture it's
the habits we've developed as a
collective they're our Collective
knowledge Collective wisdom people talk
about there's all these sort of informal
terms but it's things that you can learn
from other people
keep yourself fed and not get hurt and
stuff like that right and that acts as a
prior on your decision making so if you
don't know anything about the situation
you turn to the prior you just do what
other people do and in Rome do as the
Romans do if you know a lot about it
like you're an expert about this thing
then the prior maybe you'll use it a
little bit but you actually know enough
about this to be on enough enough
personal experience or not observational
experience that you can sort of reason
it out and so people have this fluid way
of going back and forth and I'll show
you that and what that gives you is a
posterior which generates which action
you're going to take
okay
now some of you very few of you remember
things like shaky the robot and strips
so these are early AI things it's
basically trying to find rules that in
this context this rule works that was a
lot of early eyes sort of an
action-oriented expert system type of I
think anyway you don't care
um
so so this type of model has rationality
in it but it's also continually learning
and integrating other people's
experiences
and it's not primarily a deductive model
it's not like representation and
knowledge so much as strategies for
getting along and accomplishing things
context sensitive strategies okay so
let's think of this often this is called
Try by
so you try things if you like them then
you do them again and again and again
and again that's the exploitation
exploitation thing so this is actually
um 10 to the 8th people's
credit card records
be afraid you know this is done inside
one of these big Banks where we you know
could look at their data and try and
understand and what you're seeing here
is that what people do is they go to a
few places and they buy things those are
those big things and they tend to return
them those are the big arrows right so
think of this as a Markov model
so you know get up in the morning you
have your coffee and you go to work have
some more coffee you go to the
supermarket that's number five every
once in a while and then you go home
right so those are the things you do but
you also do these other places in your
environment occasionally
and you can see when somebody moves to a
new place they do a lot more exploration
because they don't know what's going on
and some of these things out there that
you try will become the go-to places
and other ones will fall off so what
you've got is this continual exploration
process
to have exploitation of the things that
you like and that evolves over time and
everybody does this right this is this
is the universal pattern when you get to
be really really familiar with places
you don't explore as much
um
you see this same behavior in bees and
other social animals
right they go out and they try things
and then they settle into a pattern but
they continue to explore some
um
it's a little bit like for those of you
who are more math oriented like mcmc
Markov uh chain Martin Carla because you
have lots of elements out there doing
these you know Markov chains for
exploration where what they're doing is
updating their transition patterns over
time and you reach an equilibrium as a
population
for which things are useful to the
population and which things aren't in
other words if something's very popular
right that means lots of people in the
neighborhood through their exploration
process found it to be good okay and in
fact this process has been supercharged
in most uh social species like in bees
where the bee fines a lot of pollen it
comes back to the hive and does this
waggle dance that tells people other
people where the pollen isn't the more
bees go out and they all come back and
they do this little waggle dance and
then you have more bees and if there's
enough pollen there what happens the
whole Hive picks up and moves
okay you see the same thing in ape
troops so to figure out where to go they
all sort of like hoot at each other for
a while and then eventually one group
wins the hooting thing and they go off
that way and we have Yelp okay
but you know
what that's interesting is is this is a
sort of a collective judgment about
which things are good and which things
aren't right this is I would claim a
version of collective rationality
for the population in a region the
things that are popular the things that
the people like
it's sort of dull right you know and
they find it through this exploration
process so if a new store opens up it
has the possibility of joining the best
list
um but it depends on people visiting it
and then deciding that there's going to
be a go-to place
because I just want to show you that
because sometimes it's a little hard to
understand this stuff
so um
in recent years we've been like working
on the math of this and so what you've
got is you've got all these agents
trying to figure out what's best for
them right and they talk to each other
and they observe each other
okay but that observation is noisy
sometimes what you like isn't what I
like
so you have to decide who has the same
utility function as you
because if you learn if they look if you
like the same sort of coffee I do I'm
going to watch where you go and and and
follow you and you have noisy
communication because language is not
actually about the truth it's about sort
of what's on the top of our head and so
forth right so
uh we have developed things that are
very much like human behavior so you get
bad guys in there you get people with
different utilities you get noise
still converges to this Optimum
and the part that's really different is
this sort of business of exploration and
learning from each other you can prove
optimality
optimality in this sense is minimum
regret so you waste effort the minimum
amount of time
waste effort on bad arms bad choices the
minimum amount of time both as an
individual
and as a group
so that sounds like preservation of the
species to me
we've got a certain amount of energy
certain amount of choices to make
certain amount of time you want to make
the best choices you can you have to
explore because you don't know much
about what's going on and things change
here's your optimality proof
yeah worth paying attention to
for that reason I you may disagree with
me that's great but um most of the
models don't come with a sort of
quote-unquote fitness optimality and I'm
you know I'm waving my hands a little
bit here but just a little bit
so so pay attention to that
interestingly
you can make this robust to those long
tail things
so I mentioned at the beginning why be a
social species well because you have all
these Cascade processes and you have
preferential attachment and it's just
going to screw up your reasoning
you can make this so that it's robust to
that and it's optimal up to like
necklace limits is optimal for uh
changeable distributions you don't have
to assume equilibrium
right so a lot of the things people
assume in these things like
it's all stable okay well yes right it's
all sort of compact distributions yeah
well sorry no
um a lot of the things that people
assume away and are responsible for our
systems crashing and burning as a
consequence because we've made
assumptions that are just not true of
the world
can be handled by this class a model
sir just a quick question in this
do I observe the others Rewards or their
rewards private
you can observe uh so the simple one is
You observe the other people's rewards
right
um you can observe Aggregates of rewards
and noisy Aggregates of rewards and
noisy Aggregates of awards with people
who are lying to you
and you've still got optimality but
obviously there's limits to all of this
right okay so yeah so that's just like
not bad right you know so
um and is it a perfect simulation of
people no right but but the is this sort
of basic math is like saying you know
logic is is good and we cannot try to
sort of describe things it happens when
you have uh
the population's cluster right so the
when I'm I don't have a visibility into
everyone I may just have my local
neighborhood yeah and so that made bias
my my estimates and my observations you
can get Echo Chambers and even more you
select your neighborhood right right so
what you select are people who have that
you can learn from optimally which are
people that are like you have the same
utility function so it enforces
homophily so natural homography is a
natural thing but there's a conscious
thing too which is that if you're going
to really once you get homophily what
that does is everyone is doing the same
things so you don't learn as much so
there's a real payoff to observing
people who aren't like you even though
it's noisy
so what you get is you get this block
stochastic structure naturally emerging
where the value comes from a lot of
value comes from observing people far
out but those are very noisy signals
and and then there's the sort of local
uh portfolio of decisions that you make
that you've vetted with people who are
like you
or is this some notion of like the
collective's regret interesting thing is
it's both
that's like wow really so it's the
collective but for each individual it
also has an optimality they're slightly
different optimalities but yeah and
that's really interesting so it's a good
strategy for you but it's a good
strategy for your tribe also
Ah that's interesting so look at it I
mean you know I'm speaking English so
that means it's not the math
okay so look at the math so um in
um I'm taking long hair I apologize
um
so in the psychological literature
there's this guy by the economy and
diversky that won a Nobel Prize for
decision Theory and they talked about
system one and system two so do people
generally know about that many people do
some people do anyway so system one is
supposed to be like this at a automatic
thing that sort of like simple rules you
apply and this is actually the vast
majority of your decisions right which
where where you go which drink what you
eat you don't think about it after a
while it's just built in as this little
routine and then you have a reflective
thing which is the conscious mind
because this is mostly unconsciousness
system one and then system two is this
sort of reflective logic think about it
is this really good for me uh we were
talking earlier today about quitting
smoking once you've started smoking it's
all system one stuff it's like you feel
this you put the thing in your mouth
before you even realize what you're
doing it's really hard to stop smoking
because system two and system one don't
talk to to each other much okay now
there's a lot of reason to believe that
this is really good got a Nobel Prize
all that stuff but it's probably too
much of a cartoon
because those things do talk to each
other
incidentally system one
is the social one
it's about Norms copying other people
system two is much more individual
so there's that Dimension to it too so I
you can map this onto this
exploration exploitation thing where
the the likelihood of something given
the features is your rational mind right
and then that's that system too that's
slow painful you don't use it all that
often blah blah blah we go to university
to get to learn how to do it it's it's
not a natural thing and then system one
which is the thing that like you know
four-year-olds have and five-year-olds
have and stuff like that comes from
social cues mostly
and those social cues therefore uh uh
reflect the common Norms in your
environment
and you'd like those to be collectively
rational you'd like them to be true
in the sense of being helpful to your
Fitness as a tribe just like you'd like
the individual rationality to be helpful
to you to survive
okay
uh and then get the posteriors
so this is something one of my students
ziv who's like a superstar uh uh type of
guy did just recently he built a social
media
a platform where people would Doom
scroll just like they normally do but he
would measure how much you dwelled on
things like how long did you pause or
spend on something and then whether you
actually dove into it and like read the
article that type of thing it did with
images and did it with text and what you
find is this tri-stage which is like
your flip Doom scroll lady you're trying
to decide what to actually look at right
um is is very much sort of stage 1A type
stuff and it's focused on Sensational uh
things but it's not attentive to
Credible posts The credibility of the
post okay and it is very influenced by
social things
on the other hand the buy things the
ones that you put in on are much more
focused on credible things and not
sensational
so there's some good news there so what
he's found is is that if you get people
to pause before they forward things
and just sort of consider credibility so
they they don't just forward things
because the title's cool they actually
look at it first
and then only then they forward it they
do a much better job of avoiding fake
news
interesting but here's this try versus
spy you're exploring what everybody else
is doing and then you're selecting
things and you only like really spend
energy on things that you find credible
and useful
okay or
for instance music lab people know what
music lab is okay so music lab people
made a bunch of fake music worlds uh
that had social feedback or not social
feedback and what we found was that
again this Try by architecture people
would pick things based on the title and
the social number of sort of people who
had looked at it and so forth that was
very perfectly predicted which things
you would would sample you'd listen to a
little bit of it but the ones who would
actually download were individual
because I'm based on on things that you
liked
and this is rather also like a visual
search which is you know we can scan
things and pick out certain things
amazingly well like this is find Waldo
people know that
generational problems when you have
little kids you try to find Waldo right
you know a little stripy character in
this messy thing we're actually really
good at that sort of stuff appallingly
good but then understanding what to do
with it and taking action based on that
is a much slower process
right so again it looks like this Try by
thing which is right okay and we do the
same thing in more complex situations so
this is a platform that we've uh focused
on a lot this is etoro It's a finite
social trading platform so um you can
buy and sell stocks and stuff like that
right but you can also see what other
people's strategies are and how they're
doing
so I can say oh yeah she's long on the
Euro and short on the Yen or whatever
and she's doing really well okay now I
don't know how much money you put into
this but I can see how much she did in
the last week or last month and things
like that so there's this sort of social
feedback
and then there's your own like what am I
actually going to put my money in
because it's real money
typical money is on the order of ten
thousand bucks it matters right okay and
what we find is is that this notion of
what people invest in is really
extremely well described by this uh
distributed Bandit origin distributed
Thompson thing where it's popularity
literally times performance in the last
little while
uh uh dictates the posterior and you
construct a portfolio based on this
posterior and that's what actually
across hundreds of thousands of people
all around the world is what people do
so they what they don't do
is they don't make decisions based on uh
the properties of the trade itself
okay so has this been a good trade
recently
what they do is is has this been a good
trade recently and do lots of other
people do it too
and that predicts what they do quite
accurately and there's a nice paper and
cognition about this where is that oh
yeah so Bayesian collective learning
emerges from heuristic social learning
so we're very limitedly rational these
are very limited sort of individual
things but they are collectively
rational which means that the the group
of people actually have something that
is very near optimal investment
strategies portfolio
think about a bunch of idiots out there
like day Traders gambling their money
individually they're okay
they make a lot of mistakes but
collectively they're really good
interesting
and the other sort of stupid thing is
that people don't follow the collective
as much as they should
right when they start off they use
stereotypes to guide their notion of
Social and it turns out to be sort of
bad like you know you you follow other
people of the same nationality or other
people that are the same you know uh
some other sort of property anyway you
should read the paper it's interesting
um the key observations are these very
simple heuristics about is this a good
thing or not uh plus social sampling you
know they're looking at the people
around you yields a collective
rationality
that's pretty amazing actually if you
think about it again right so it's good
for the people because they feed that
back into their decisions
um
but it also suggests a lot of things
with human computer interface
I think it was just nominally what this
is about right so like for instance to
improve in performance
um you could do better risk management
you could cue people that when they
choose a posterior they should pay
attention to the risk you could have
them use better features for their uh
personal estimates for their system 2E
sort of thinking about it people resort
to stereotypes too often and that hurts
their performance you can help them by
giving them tools to make better
estimates to sort of showing them what
happens
you could do better sampling of the
social situation
better sampling of other people tend to
not choose other people to learn from
optimally okay and you could give them
help in doing that so that they don't
choose a bunch of people that are
similar too similar to them because
remember there's this tension between
validating by people that are similar to
you and learning new strategies from
people who aren't similar to you so you
can give them a little bit of that let
me just show you really quickly
so um this is the number of people you
pay attention to down here
yeah there's about 15 people and your
profitability at making trades it's
across hundreds of thousands of people
for years right so people can pay
attention we're limited I don't pay
attention to about 15 other people and
if you try to do more than that you
screw up
okay
that's interesting
if you
intervene
and you say oh well those 15 people
should be people with different
strategies
okay not all the same because people
tend to say oh this one's good and then
they'll pick another one that's almost
the same it's highly correlated so
you're making the spread of their
strategies broader
that helps you can also do things where
the machine pays attention to the
different strategies and selectively
adds a few back to people
right to help them keep track of things
perhaps by saying oh well you should use
this new one rather than that one that's
too similar to the other ones because
it's highly correlated and you can get
an increase to Performance that way
just saying if you want to make money
um you can get better tools so I talked
about long tail distributions
so in these things if you have a machine
doing it
um you know what happens is because
trading is a stocks and things like that
are cascade processes they're
preferential attachment
I think the the rich get if it's pop
they're mean stocks everything's a mean
stock lots of momentum in there right
okay so if you use standard methods that
assume uh concentrated distributions
like gaussians
you converge to best strategies
relatively slowly but if you use math
that takes into account the long tail
you can do very very much better there's
a paper about that what that is actually
is this is when you get an outlier
you keep it aside so well this doesn't
fit the metals I have right you keep it
aside and you ask are any of the models
that I have actually long tail but I
didn't know that
so you keep a little index of weird
stuff
and you go back and you ask each time
you get weird stuff
um could this actually be a distribution
that's not a concentrated distribution
and if you do that then you discover
those long tail things fairly quickly
and your estimate converges really fast
okay it's not really it's sort of a you
can imagine humans doing this tell
stories about the weird stuff just so
you recognize that things can be strange
sometimes
who knows about
um the great flood of California it's a
fun thing
so in 1862
the Central Valley was under 30 feet of
water
think about that for a minute right
because the rains were so dramatic that
they couldn't rain fast enough and
apparently this happens every 100 150
years
normally right over historical time
so so don't buy things near sea level
for another reason
go up on the hill a little bit anyway
um
here's you might say Okay so the stuff
I've shown you is about regular people
not experts so we did an experiment with
experts those of you who do social
science will appreciate this we got the
experts to pay us lots of money to be in
the experiment
okay we called it a class right
and they paid money to be in class and
one of the things we did was an
experiment in the class and what we did
is we asked these were mid-career
financial traders experts 40 years old
trade hundreds of millions of dollars
they know what they're doing right and
we asked them to predict future prices
on various asset classes
okay we gave them the price history and
they know these things and then they
made a prediction and then we showed
them what everybody else did
okay and ask them would you like to
change your prediction
so we showed them the social prior
and they were really really good at
um at the individual logic okay because
they did this for a living so what do
you think happened
I'll tell you what happened
dude so the people who use the social
made less money
well that's weird not a lot less money
we're talking about like half a percent
there right and the people that were all
Quan did a little bit better
so what's going on there right
but if you look at it slightly
differently which is actually the
correct way to look at it which is risk
right so yeah you do better but
sometimes you blow it really badly
so actually in trading having started a
couple of hedge funds I know this
you get killed by things that are
unexpected it's not like that you can
make a little money each trade is that
trade that loses 50 percent that kills
the whole thing right so what you find
is the people that are more social you
have much less risk and so over repeated
trials
they're going to come out better so they
trade a little bit in the present
for the long-term aggregation because
they never lose that 50 percent
that's interesting
um
so
um this social prior as you commented is
affected by
um so your preferential attachment the
people you pay attention to so if you
look at uh things and how popular are
you can come
with uh problems you can see problems in
the way we think like for I'll do this
real quick but I'll show the interesting
thing
um so demand Supply bro how many take
like econ 101
fun with linear functions right that
sort of thing
um so as the price goes so price goes
down the quantity of stuff goes up and
people begin to manufacture more of it
but if you're in a regime with
preferential attachment in other words
people speak to each other and say ah
this is really good and recommended the
way say online social markets are what
you get is you get a very different
thing
because now the prior for your decision
is changing as a function of the
popularity so as it becomes more popular
you're much more likely to buy it in a
non-linear fashion
because of the social popularity
and of course the same thing happens
with the suppliers they think oh this is
the next big thing we're going to make a
lot of it and it takes off
that has implications
this is a recent paper
so we looked at various markets and how
the big guys versus the little guys work
right so this is a little hard to see
but
um
so
vertical there is your rank so the 500
are the little guys you've never heard
of the big guys are like Amazon meta
things like that okay
if you have random perturbations in
there in a preferential attachment thing
turns out the big guys
um barely budge they're not affected
about that because they have lots of
people attracting them now the people so
so they're very robust in staying there
despite turbulence in the market
the little guys tend to get better
because they can't get worse right and
they get little bits of punch from the
from preferential attachment it's the
guys in the midterm
sort of B rounds or C round they get
slobbered right because they don't have
enough uh popularity
to resist random permutations
okay oh this sounds so this is what I
just showed you I'm doing this quick but
here's real data so Amazon these are
popularity of things on Amazon the most
popular ones hardly ever change out of
being the most popular one the ones that
are a little less popular have real
probability of decreasing so unless
you're the leader
you've got real problems but if you're a
little guy
you'll tend to do better
okay I know these are a little hard to
read
but but here's the interesting thing
is that we had a paper in uh proceedings
the National Academy of Science showing
that
um
if you make this inequality and
preferential attachment big enough so
it's a very strongly preferential
attachment then you get Market
domination
inevitably
right so when most people are not all
that good at advertising and I don't
have that much mind share but a few
people do
they're go they're guaranteed to become
completely dominant in the market and if
you take one of them out
one of the others the number two just
replaces it so getting rid of meta isn't
going to fix it there'll be a number two
that comes in there okay
um
where you get a good performance I don't
know why that's not showing up quite
well let's see if I
yeah here we go
where you get good Dynamics and sort of
competition you like to see is where the
the different competitors are more or
less equal in their mind share in their
attention chair all right so that's the
thing you should focus on not market
share attention share
and in that case you get competition so
I'm going to quit there
um sorry I had to rush that last a
little better so
taking this sort of strategy exploration
as opposed to individual rationality
approach allows you to integrate the
social and the individual
and actually describes a lot of
phenomena that we see in a much more
integrated way than other ways of
approaching it
um you can get collectively rational
performance out of very limited actors
which is good for us because we're
limited and we'd like to be collectively
rational but you have to be very careful
about this because you need good social
sampling to do this
and bad social sampling is called
marketing
or people who dominate Twitter right so
so those are things that make you think
that something is very popular so you
look at it more seriously
and that causes a lot of the problems
because it distorts your judgment
right because you think everybody else
Isis used this just incredible ways to
get people to go to Syria
to get killed right just in ways they
manipulated it so that these poor guys
thought that everybody was going to
Syria
right and and so they did right and the
same thing with October 6th and stuff
and it's just crazy
um experts use the same strategy and in
fact they achieve what I would think
characterized as a parental optimal uh
strategy so they're mixing social for
risk control
but they're individually quite good
at deciding what to do that doesn't mean
they can't do better like for instance
showing them long tail distributions
will improve their performance showing
them other sort of strategies will
perform their uh performance so even
with experts and so the final thing is
is that in a lot of these things you
have to be really careful about the
social prior particularly the sampling
what is the audience that people are
reacting to because that inevitably
influences the decisions that we make
Okay so
good thank you
seven plus minutes which is not quite
enough but
so if you talk about this like trying to
buy three
in the compacts uh is it reasonable to
think about it even the try stage is
already like some sort of biology paper
because on social media if I'm waiting
to look at the poster for one second it
means that I'm engaging with the content
it's already like a bad behavior versus
the buy uh metrics you mentioned such as
likes or tweets or whatever that's more
likely to say the same so obviously
that's a sort of a gray thing so in a
music lab thing
you got to look at things and you could
hear a little bit of the clip but the
buy was I'm actually going to download
it so I can listen to the whole thing so
it's sort of distinct but yes clearly
um in the social media thing you're
scrolling through you know your normal
you know a standard looking social media
thing and it's a question of which ones
do you stop on for a second so it's a
type of buy yeah sure but you're not
actually clicking on the thing you're
just like is this something I want to
invest some time on right so you're
trying it so try it has this notion it's
like when you go to a new restaurant I
don't know let's try it out well you
know you're committed to actually paying
the money and eating things and so forth
but but you may never go back
if it Buy in this case would be I'm
going to go back and back and back right
and and the the point of all that is not
to make this such a dichotomous thing
which is the way it's described in
system one system two but it's really
this Continuum of of exploration to find
better strategies and you need to invest
some in exploring and you get some
losers uh in order to come up with
things like that and when you include
sociality in there people with similar
utility functions then as a group you
can come up with a set of strategies
that it has this optimality property uh
for the group
and I'm not saying optimality doesn't
mean it's like the best of all possible
things it means that it's a minimum
regret strategy
too I I like the fact that they those
two systems talk to each other but I
still found sometimes it's really harder
to uh see whether something is more
existing or more system too like the
restaurant example I go to a restaurant
because there are a lot of people
waiting a lot I know it's great so so
yeah so
um condom and diversity put out the
system one system too it's a very
popular framework
there's a lot of criticism of it that in
fact they're not separate
okay so for instance the the system one
stuff Shades in the system too as you're
just pointing out right they're really
not distinct system two is not in
entirely individual because you have
this sort of well but if I do that
she'll think that blah blah blah sort of
stuff system one is not entirely social
norms that could be idiosyncratic
um you know there's a lot of evidence
though that that so so what this is
trying to do is say no actually they are
part of the same system
and the thing that ties them together
is this exploration exploitation
so when something is really clearly in
the exploitation thing you've done it a
bunch of times and so forth then that
looks much more like System One stock
right
yeah
sir and then you oh yeah okay I'll be
fast okay I I take your point to
basically be you know we pay attention
to each other good that actually can
produce some great outcomes but we don't
always pay attention to the right people
that can sort of knock us out of the
writing equilibrium yep uh and and I
think your point to be basically what we
need is Broad Social sampling if we want
to avoid that problem especially on that
most that last project you're talking
about
so that means that we essentially have
to reduce the sortativity right that we
have to kind of be listening across
partisan in some sense to get to get
those signals but then but then visually
rational to do due to things like social
acceptance and other kinds of like there
are incentives that sort of keep us
assortative right so I'm curious if like
if I just give you a soapbox for a
minute about what kinds of shifts to
sort of
you know the environment the design
environment our individual psychology
would produce those kinds of outcomes
more often than we see them today I'm
thinking in particular here spending so
much time thinking about social media
recently you know there's such an
individual incentive to be to be
assortative
I don't know how we you know what what
shifts to the environment would actually
undo that so um
the work you know world's like
optimality and minimum regret are a
little tricky in this sense right
um so given the situation this is what
your group will decide is the right
strategy okay so that is your judgment
and given the evidence that you have
is probably pretty good
according to this however the group and
the information you have could be all
screwy
okay and if I can give you additional
information this trusted information uh
about the the situation then you may
shift your strategy so what this is
saying is I'm not telling you what the
new facts are or old facts or anything
so I'm not making an argument from logic
I'm making an argument about what
strategies are are likely to be good for
you I'm not telling you about that I'm
going to let you decide but I'm going to
give you basically I'm telling you the
game that you're playing is not the
right game
here's some other things you haven't
considered let me give you an example
so if you go in and you ask uh people
see uh like the people in this room
about what the right wing thinks about
undermining democracy where this is like
strong man versus elected leader
um they think that the right win guys
are like all about autocracy and stuff
like that but if you ask the right-wing
guys about it right in a neutral thing
like Pew charitable trust sort of people
these are the real opinions dramatically
wrong
okay and so one way to think about this
is that what the Press does is it
highlights crazy people
right that way you'll read it
right okay so nut picking is the phrase
that people use interestingly and you
guys won't like this
this is the rights belief about the left
opinions oh sorry you didn't like the
previous one okay this is the rights
belief about the left opinions the left
opinions think that you're a bunch of
the right people right when people think
you're a bunch of crazies okay but if we
actually go in and ask you
there's your real opinions about
undermining democracy okay you will
notice that those look very similar
okay
oh that's not popular in this room okay
but
this is like
this is uh 5 000 people and it was just
replicated here at Stanford in
comparison of 140 different strategies
to about how can you reinforce democracy
Willer is a the guy that ran that same
results right this was also the sort of
the top uh or one of the two top
performing strategies for this sort of
thing so if you show people this you
have just a little online thing saying
oh actually no actually you know the
people on the other side have these
beliefs you know concrete things like uh
willing to do uh uh suppression of the
press things like that very concrete
things they actually changed their
voting behavior
actually changed their voting behavior
it was like a five-minute intervention
you can go see it it's online right
that's amazing so what you're doing here
is you're giving them data
uh about the situation that they hadn't
seen before and it causes them to change
their strategy now they don't become 100
the other way but they do change their
opinion and their strategy quite a bit
and it lasts for at least a couple weeks
well that's interesting and and I I
think that this is a little bit like
those experts those financial experts
you know this financial experts have
been doing this for 20 years they handle
hundreds of millions of dollars they
know what the heck they're doing but
when you say oh by the way all the
auditor Traders are more bearish than
you
they'll say hmm maybe I should
reconsider just for sort of risk control
so the strategy that they pick is more
like the other people and they move a
fair amount in fact the amount that the
expert Traders move based on social cues
is rather similar to this
I mean in terms of amplitude
yeah sir ma'am
um
good social sampling versus exactly
um I was curious about how you might
model
trust into internet model that that was
uh up there earlier of observing you
know Neighbors in a community observing
their behavior for instance I might
trust my neighbor more than I trust
somebody on Yelp who has the same
opinion or I might Trust
so here's the data that we have about
that
is that first of all
um
you're more likely to trust people that
share a lot of similar circumstances
with you so in particular people who
live near you and have the same policing
the same medical the same this you know
because like their all your decisions
are shaped by sort of common
circumstances
um if you find people who pay attention
to each other so like I reach out to you
and ask your opinion or you reach out
and you reach out to me
well that means that I find your opinion
valuable and you find my opinion
valuable
when you take pairs of people like that
and you ask them things like would you
loan that guy a hundred bucks
the answer is yes
if you take people who aren't like that
the answer is no and the accuracy of
this is some crazy number like 95
percent
right it's really predictive of trust so
so what
an interpretation of that is
and I must say it was like 100 so trust
is mutual expected Mutual value
right and we trade things
interestingly uh there have been some
studies recently that show that there's
your homophily group the people who are
like you but that you also people have
these persistent long-range ties
so they're not weak ties and that's the
traditional thing you know you've got no
opportunities through oh these are
fairly strong ties but they're long
distance in the sense that they go to a
very different community
and people hold on to those
and most of the sort of new things they
do come over those
so that's highly correlated with wealth
creation better life outcomes
stuff like that
so it's interesting so there's this
tension between your in-group the people
who are like you and the people who are
not like you and when you can conform
these trusted relationships with people
who are not like you those are
incredibly valuable is that what's the
evidence
um and and they're persistent because
you expect that they'll continue to be
valuable which I would take to be a good
definition of the word trust
right
I know it's not the emotional subjective
thing but it's this you know yeah the
guy has my back there's there's like
they're giving me the good stuff that
type of I think
sort of inherent in the interrogation
like it implies the reciprocal there is
a crying
so so I mean you can give examples like
this like you know you get up and it
used to be you get up in the morning you
go down to the newsstand and you give
the guy a quarter and you give you the
newspaper and you can sort of and if you
showed up one day without a quarter he'd
give you the newspaper anyhow right so
so that's a trusted relationship you may
think the guy is an idiot and you may
hate what he stands for but you have
trust on that issue
right so that's another thing trust is
not like this generalized thing it has
to do with specific types of issues
strategies value stuff like that
okay all right I think let's thank our
speaker